[Music]
so one of the things that happens
when we grow older with our nodding
resignation
into nothingness is that we enter a kind
of consciousness known as the bin
there's and
done that's of the adult mind right it's
that notion
when nothing excites or overwhelms
anymore because you've seen it
all before and what a tragedy this is
right i mean come on i mean we all
remember
nostalgically the intensity of
experiencing something for the first
time
seeing the world through the eyes of a
child wonder struck
and entranced by awe right
succumbing to astonishment giving in
to astonishment mouth gaped wide i mean
damn to see something for the first time
but then what happens then you
assimilate you model it in your brain
store it in your library of been theirs
and done that
and you no longer engage
right sensorially with stimuli it's
called
hedonic adaptation familiarity breeds
boredom it's so depressing right
and so what do we do well i think this
is where
mindful self-inquiry comes in this is
where meditation this is where
breathing exercises and yoga comes in
this is where boarding a craft that
flies you across the world can be
therapeutic
like injecting you with a little bit of
life by
stimulating you and jet lagging you and
placing you in an entirely different
wallpaper of the mind it's what it's why
travel revitalizes
it's why people self-medicate sometimes
tweaking our perception sometimes that
marijuana joint can be the magnifying
lens or the pane of glass
that doesn't distort reality but confers
on phenomena
a certain feeling of distance as david
lenson says
perhaps that's why a museum hangs an
ordinary item and puts it on the wall
decontextualizes it and brings our
attention
back to it right we get to enter the
archetypical space where the specific
stands in for all of its kind stands in
for the universal
right we like to enter a modality of
consciousness known as
plato's realm of ideals i mean that's
where you
live in the present that's when anxiety
about the future and melancholy for the
past get drowned out by the ever-present
rapture of the now and we are free
and in that moment we are adam and eve
in the garden of eden before eating from
the tree of knowledge
knowing no death knowing only now and
the bliss
of now if only we could get back there
i support whatever works as long as you
don't hurt anybody else
you